[Music]
Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna's newborn
daughter dream makes her snapchat debut
yep that's dream Rene Kardashian just
hours after being born rocking this
snapchat flower crowd we're excited for
the new edition in my family and in
their family
the proud parents wasted no time sharing
photos of their tiny bundle of joy on
social media
check out this hilarious video posted to
China's Instagram gookju Christian a
haircut and this photo Rob uploaded
sweetly thanking his fiance for giving
birth to their baby girl and declaring
dream might be his twin but that's
definitely China's nose I'm just happy
even more touching this side by side
image Rob shared Thursday night his
daughter next to his father the late
Robert Kardashian senior he wrote quote
pop sent us an angel it's truly a
blessing if you can't get enough of the
newest Kardashian kid don't worry
there's more the Robin China baby
special will take viewers inside the
delivery room and showcase the couple's
journey as they expand their growing
family catch all the chaos and cuteness
when it airs December 18th on e I'm
gonna figure it out then be a great dad
[Music]
you